this is a production of Cornell
University as always Frank Rossi's gonna
give us a little overview here at the
start and then we've got rich Buckley
the Rutgers plant diagnostic lab and
many you guys may know rich from either
send them turf samples ornamental
samples you may have sent some samples
to him in the past so really excited to
have rich here talking about some golf
turf today
so with that Frank let's get started
Richard yeah thank you yeah yeah rich
Buckley my brother from another mother
right anyway so so let me go through
about 5-10 minutes of this I do not want
to waste a minute of Rich's time to talk
about all the things I've got on my mind
regarding areas that you know he's on
the frontlines of the turf grass
epidemics that are every year so good we
can call me Andy fat Anthony Falchi of
the turf grass industry if we we get
generous later so listen here we are
still trying to support each other
through these challenging times and I'm
sure if you know the further south you
are in this region whether you're
playing golf or not on your courses the
demand for your time and the inability
to watch these sorts of videos that are
happening in the middle of the day
webinars in the middle of the day
certainly we sympathize with you that's
why we're recording them and hope you
enjoy them later on and that a picture
like this puts a smile on your face so
you know I limit I have to pay attention
to how much I look at things I'm the
anxious type so when I see something
really positive I'm always happy to do
it just love this if this is the result
of what comes out of this thing I'm not
entirely sure that it's a bad thing all
around but but kudos to this gal course
superintendent bringing the kids out
there and and teaching them some of the
cool things that we do alright with that
a word from a professor in our
department development apartment
department here at the College of Ag you
know we need more connection not less
more sharing information more
collaboration and that's why we're
bringing guests on all the time because
you know I'm been around long enough to
know I got my ideas about things and
Carl will tell you they're crazy at
times but but we validate it by chatting
with other people right so we need more
collaboration for more solutions you can
bet the people who are studying Co vid
are actively finding a way to
communicate with each other on the
latest advancements be them in the
corporate world or in the in the
university settings as well so hopefully
this contributes to this solution if
you'd like more information you know
we're in our 21st year of distributing
this fairly wide thousands of people
read our newsletter that comes out on a
weekly basis and rich has been a strong
part of that over the 20 years we've
been doing it so if you'd like to read
more about what's going on not just
listen to the video but read more you
can sign up for free and this is this
week's issue of course always to pay
attention to what our major national and
local chapters are doing right all the
chapters are putting information out
especially pay attention to your chapter
resources at this time and I'll talk to
you in a minute if why that is first off
is the update compared to last week
there's I think there's one more state
that's allowing off or one more state
where there's a state order in place no
golf so this is a big impact of the way
you're going to manage it it's something
like seventy something percent could
play now when you look at real carefully
the ng up just put this out recently if
you look real carefully at who's open
and playing you see that even when
states are open there's this patchwork
of who's open and who's closed right
like some of these green dots may be
state park golf courses some of these
green dots might be in Onondaga County
right you can play golf in New York but
you can't in certain counties yeah so I
think this is where the confusion is
coming in and I'm hoping this is a place
where the local chapters the brand-new
GCS a and why the Mets superintendents
the Long Island and wingman guys New
Jersey guys Pennsylvania you all have to
be paying attention to what the local
things are saying as well about play
thanks to Carl for getting this snap in
this picture of a family at the Robert
Trent Jones Golf Course in desperate
need of a bunker renovation you can see
but people flying a kite right in front
of the 6th green alright so just because
you're close is a great article that
this young man in Wisconsin wrote about
what's happening he's putting signs up
and people are going out there and you
know using the golf course for these
purposes it's been a very interesting
discussion in the industry about well
how's golf different than this
you know it's four people playing golf
they're not close they're not touching
anything why is this okay and Golf is
not okay
and I promise you that conversation is
not over but from a growing grass
perspective does this put any traffic on
your turf that you have to manage for do
you have to put up additional signage if
you're spraying pesticides or you're
trying to work and there's 50 kites
being flown on your golf course where
are the rules and regulations again
because that could ultimately govern the
way you manage so again are they playing
is there traffic the GSA at it's a
pandemic resource site has listed to
minimum maintenance plans one for when
you're closed and one for when you're
open so of all the things that are
listed in minimum maintenance it's
basically saying you should be mowing
and spraying when you're closed right
now Rick we're gonna talk in a minute
about spraying that's part of it right
we've talked a little bit about growth
and nutrient management up to this point
we don't think there's a lot of things
you should be spraying right now I
personally don't Rick is gonna rich is
gonna correct me in a minute if I'm
wrong but the reality is looks like what
we're doing is mowing what I think is
fascinating here if you're closed
they're basically saying mow two to
three times per week of your greens this
is very interesting to see this because
I agree with some of these things one to
two times a week on tees one to two
times on fairways one time per week
based on weather collars approaches
driving range treaty banks basically
once a
almost everything but greens are once a
week and sometimes they're saying two
times per week now if you're open for
play they're still saying greens at two
to three times per week so if you're a
golf course superintendent you're
listening to this or you're watching
this and you're mowing five and six
times a week because you got play out
there that's not considered minimum
maintenance our National Association is
basically saying we can back off on some
of these things what do we have to
provide these conditions for that
doesn't feel like minimum maintenance
this to me is a bit of a shift from some
of the things I said I saw coming out
last week obviously Safety's at the top
and you can get these resources yeah
it's right there for you on the website
you can click to find it now what's
interesting is you get down to the
bottom there with its fertility and
chemical stuff is you know this is not
the time to skip these applications
minimize nitrogen use to slow growth all
on board with that use ns your true
growth regulator clipping yield should
be low to facilitate the reduction in
mowing well you don't know what you're
clipping yield is if you're not
measuring it you're estimating it from
there you're not measuring it now I want
to say right here I forgot to put the
slide in Doug sold that at Wisconsin
University of Wisconsin has updated
Excel spreadsheet and then Carla put a
link to it in the chat box that you can
find he put out a new Excel spreadsheet
that'll help you just enter your value
and it calculates all the all the things
you need to know about that but here's
what the USDA just put out a big kudos
to Adam Miller and all the agronomists
they're just they're doing a spectacular
job and keeping everybody updated on
this but this is a frequently asked
question how high can I raise my mowing
height screen tees and fairways without
causing issues down the road here's what
they've said they said you can go to
3/16 now I believe we've said well if
you're gonna keep it at 180 you can
almost let it go over to before you have
to mow it and what we've talked about
with Bill in the past bilk riser is that
the higher you mow and the less
frequently you mow and follow the one
third rule the less growth you will get
right could be very interesting playing
golf courses mode at 3/16 of an inch
that's the height of cut it was when I
started in his business in the 70s now
they end up this really good frequently
asked questions section by by making a
really bold statement here right the
challenging parts of maintaining golf
courses during the pandemic is staying
focused on keeping golf course turf
healthy rather than focusing on
playability under normal circumstances
playing conditions and turf health are
equally important but we're in
unprecedented times so the focus needs
to be adjusted and I hope I hope I hope
we're all thinking about adjusting that
moving forward now let's talk a little
data soil temperature from last week let
me get rid of this thing
so I'll temperature from last week and I
think you'll see how it's progressed
right soil temperature last week soil
temperature this week and it looks like
we're just cracking into the low to mid
50s in the New York metropolitan area
down where rich is sitting
it could be solid mid 50s and we'll talk
about what that means in a second but
this is the first piece of data you
should be using to begin to govern your
minimal maintenance which will adjust
over time right here's the forecast that
we talked about last week from a growing
degree day per spective how much will
the growing season advance and here's
this week very very slow progression a
real cool week expected you know a real
cool week ahead very low growing degree
day a cumulation for much of the
Northeast even where you are rich we're
just not going to see an enormous amount
of advancing this coming week so again
good news for us as we and especially in
the New York metropolitan area wait this
out of the epicenter of this thing wait
this thing out having the growing season
at kiste at bay is a real good benefit
for us at this time now while we're
talking about top growth I promise you
root growth is very very active at this
time and and this is a massive benefit
to cutting back mowing
see you can allow for routes that you
might need later on in the season either
as you're recovering your golf courses
or you're simply trying to withstand a
drought the deeper and more prolific
that root system is which will be
greater if you're not mowing as much
right mowing disrupts that rooting
energy that's put into having to replace
leaf tissue is not used for routing
right and for top growth and routing
we're only at we're still below 25% in
the growth potential right this is the
potential for the percent of a hundred
percent growth we can get when
photosynthesis is maximized in the
upper-60s we're still only at about 25
percent so we're not you know
potentially growing that much now let's
look at the grass as we deal with in in
golf courses a little more closely an
out urgent and Joe Vargas did these
charts many many years ago that we've
relied on and I'm sure everybody's
learned it's ever taken a seminar with
these guys has learned from these things
so here's the way annual bluegrass gets
grown you're getting good root growth
now in the spring we're still well
before seed had formation now of course
our thinking has changed a little bit
that seed head formation let me see if I
can do this yeah seed head formation now
al Aaron Patten is starting to say is
maybe occurring at the latter part of
the season and that's where something
like proxy applied at that time may be
more beneficial because that's when the
seed head is actually forming but if
you're looking at what's happening
here's where we are right now angle
bluegrass is rooting really good and
some of you are probably getting some
good active top growth now creeping
bentgrass is historically you know just
a dog at this time it just sits there it
just sits there and one of the first
things we do is but especially with
those that have been grass is that is
that take all patch application right
that will talk to rich about in a minute
but a lot of it is the early signs of
root growth there those roots are
getting going quite a bit earlier this
is almost like a warm
and grass so if you look at them overlay
right let me just ask a simple question
if you want to grow Bank rats in annual
bluegrass what the hell are we spraying
an annual bluegrass at this time of year
for maybe this is an opportunity to
reduce and see a shift if we really want
more Bank rests if we really think Bank
rests is the long term solution to a lot
of our problems and we've got this
situation right now and so much of its
dependent on whether you're playing you
know how much money you got how big the
crew you know all these factors I'm just
saying
ecologically you have a time now where
if you hold things from annual bluegrass
you potentially limit its competitive
advantage and if you don't need annual
bluegrass on your golf course are you
trying to shift the bank grass because
you don't get a lot of traffic and you
think it can help you drive the
maintenance down I see that as a unique
opportunity to do it now with regard to
that and of course the work at Rutgers
showed this Katey deals work with uh
with with annual bluegrass weeble you
know you want to take out your round
your bluegrass you can use the Weeble to
do it here's a couple of tweets from two
of our leading you know friends and on
the entomology side Ben McGraw Steve
McDonald indicating we're still plenty
of time we're holding pattern we want to
get maximum emergence right you're gonna
get one shot at this you can't make five
insecticide applications this year folks
I don't think we're gonna get the choice
and if we're limited we gotta use data
to get this right there's no substitute
for going out and looking for yourself
pitfall tracts vacuums we've talked
about this with Kyle in the past let me
for them doing that it now as we
transition in my conversation with rich
you know these are the things that are
on my mind rich you know anthracnose
microd opium Pythium root rot I think
we've got a little bit of time and the
root pathogens but you know rich this is
really the issue now this was one of
those great example pictures you took
right where you've got these soil
physical problems those those kinds of
things we laugh about sometimes you know
you can't spray your way out of right if
you've got this kind of a situation you
know that picture that we showed there
you just can't spray your way out
so you know as we transition I'd like to
continue the conversation maybe we can
take the questions at the end Carl
unless you think there's a real
important question we want to get to
right now or we can start the
conversation what do you want to do so
Craig did have a question in a and it's
about nitrogen so he's still got play on
his golf course he said he's getting up
near 300 rounds on the weekend days and
so we were talking about minimum and you
know using that to govern your growth
well that sort of traffic you see I mean
minimum and you're really looking at a
growth rate so what do you think about
I'm in that situation you're probably
gonna need a little bit more in to to
recuperate from traffic stress oh god
yeah oh god yeah he's gonna need as much
I mean 300 rounds even if we were under
normal conditions would require it would
require unique unique increases in
nitrogens but here's what I you know
here's what I'd say here's what I'd say
to you Craig and again all of this
assumes so many things but let's assume
you can get the rig throw some men in it
and go out or you can get a spreader and
put on a you know a chunker and to get
you through right if you don't have the
labor resources this is the time maybe
to consider going back to a granular
source of n you can put on a greater
amount if you're talking about treat you
get good weather you talk about 300
rounds a week you're not going to be
able to spray that much n to keep up I
just think first I don't really have a
good answer about growth regulators but
my first thought would be screw and
right now it sounds like you need as
much growth as you could get I think
you're gonna need it more in the pinch
points right in the places where traffic
gets focused right you got an old place
there Van Patten you know we're you know
might be an old design and 300 people
walking in the same place it's gonna be
a bigger problem now with that much
traffic so those areas are gonna need
more I would start by treating those
areas first I would start by showing
going to my high put something in my
tank or get a spreader go to those areas
that have high traffic and start there
and then
work yourself back because you don't
want to be feeding areas that aren't
getting significantly impacted by the
traffic because then that drives up the
need for topdressing
and other sorts of things so I don't
know that seems like a crazy way to
handle it but man this is crazy time how
do L do that many golfers social
distance what the hell is a tee time
thing there well I mean good on one ego
good on you for economy but man I think
I think rich has a story about people on
Long Island hogging people on the first
tee right they wanted a hug the golf
course superintendent yeah yeah they're
trying to hug the golf course
superintendent and they're congregating
in the clubhouse you know in in in
arguably in Suffolk County the most
significant disease outbreak in the
world right now well let's keep going
fellas
what about questions Rick Karl
so that was the only question we got so
far but I'm just running this poll here
for you know asking people is their golf
course open or not so it's about 60/40
60% are not open 40% are still open so I
think that's just a good way to frame
this disease conversation once we start
talking the rich and asking about
certain diseases maybe things change
based on if you have traffic stressor
right you don't dress right so so let's
sort so it's about half and half
I mean 64 yeah that's half and half so
so rich it was my question before we
before we took the answer before we took
the questions you know this soil
temperatures are coming up let's start
with lingering diseases many people
north of the New York metropolitan area
still really aren't getting going
anywhere everybody's putting their first
cut on some might see why TIA some might
see some Pink's normal some might see
some early season anthracnose on the
whole do any of those worry you at that
time that what you know would warrant
significant intervention and how much
have you seen let's start with there how
much has come into the lab so far all
right well the lab submissions are slow
you know guys who are worried about
being closed and staffing and that sort
of stuff aren't worried about
and samples we have seen my credo quia
you know the 45-degree rainy - three
days of rain drives that disease really
nicely so we've seen a little bit of
that we've seen some some rings now you
know call brown ring patch or why taya
way dia
I think it's yellow patch actually
because the brown ring patch has a
higher temperature threshold you know
minimum you need 50 degrees and in a lab
it grows at its fastest rate at 77 so
I'm thinking what we're looking at with
the rings is yellow patch was a more
forty to sixty degree range
you know so again and there was 45 50
degree rainy periods you're seeing
yellow rings you probably get micro
dokie and probably get a little yellow
patch and you know how worried okay so
how worried are you I mean you know you
get samples all over the place guys send
you their spray records and obviously
this year maybe the spray records are
gonna look a lot lighter early on I know
that there is this pressure to keep up
you know because for 50 50 if you're not
open you're hoping at some point you're
going to be open it's not knowing what
the target is if you're not open and
there's not gonna be any golfers for the
foreseeable future what's the chances we
could you just grow out of some of these
things pretty high pretty high yeah I
mean one yellow patch or the is doesn't
really do any damage long-term right
Mike Road opium is gonna flare up and
turn off as soon as the weather changes
you know Brown ring patch has the
potential to go into the warmer weather
and cause you damage so it's a little
bit more concern there but but my you
know minimalism is a good thing at this
point I you know I saw the
recommendation you know maintained by
weekly spray schedule and I thought you
know if you're going to spray you can
get 28 days you know right now okay so
that's okay so so that's so that was
primarily foliar things but but don't
people get a little
early if they get anthracnose early what
do we know about this early season
anthracnose that might worry you well I
think I think what if you're seeing it
now I I I'm convinced that it's
overwintering infections from last fall
largely because what I see is a lot of
disease and the plugs and it's still too
damn cold to get that much fungus that
fungal activity the local temperature
range is kind of gray but it's somewhere
around 60 degrees okay you know you know
and so we're not in a soil temperature
you know which is not there yet for it
so there's no way that could be
infection from this year I don't think
so
you know you know we're always
qualifying these staff course you know
somebody needs to get a masters degree
and give us some epidemiology on that
well okay some of this is academic okay
I got interact nose now I don't care
when it happened is it gonna be a
problem in June and July because you
know I can't lose my greens at that time
yes yeah it's gonna be and hopefully has
some data from his research that the
earlier they saw it in the plots the
more damaging it was later in the season
right so if you already have disease
you're gonna get into June and even with
best management practices you're still
gonna have more you know so so I might
be trying to mitigate now now that being
said how much bang crash do you have on
your green maybe just let the pole go
he's seed some bent grass in there you
know you're a hundred percent bent or
100 percent Pawa then we mean we need to
probably try to grow out of it and and
work work toward that and how much of
that how much of your thinking changes
having said that if you're closed and
there's no traffic right I mean if you
now have two months of essentially
nothing but maintenance traffic you're
gonna get first to see the impact of
traffic but how much is the lack of
traffic for maybe a couple of months
impact how much anthracnose will occur
if that stress isn't there you did say
even if you follow the BMPs which is
higher n and you know those sorts of
things that you'll still get more that's
what hemp link showed but how much how
just not having traffic play into that I
think I think it's huge you know if you
one of the recommendations and the BMPs
is to spring your mowing height up to
one one twenty five and you just
mentioned in 180 so you Muffy's had just
exploded right if you can get the 150 or
something and price and and and and
fertilize I mean you you can have a
wicked good stand of power by the
midsummer you know that's what I think
anyway okay all right so so now the
other part of the disease discussion is
soil temperatures look right right
fifty-five sixty five degrees take all
that summer Pat's fairy ring that's the
mantra of the drenches we do in the
spring there could be an argument as
we've talked about what Bill cries are
here before it @dm eyes at this time may
actually help you with regulation again
if you're not open maximizing regulation
minimizing growth might be an advantage
what about soil temperature sprays okay
well you know that that's that's good we
need epidemia data-driven decisions
right so her husband soil temperature
and and here's the thing you don't have
to spray for something you don't have a
historical problem with how do I know I
just sprayed all the threat I don't know
if I got a historical problem because
I've been spraying for twenty years the
same thing yeah but still everybody
still gets diseases no matter how much
they spray because we put some pressure
from an agronomic standpoint on the
grass okay back at my point
how much do I gotta worry about a patch
disease if I'm not putting that stress
on it agronomic stress on I think you
have to worry a lot less and if you get
a breakthrough it's gonna the impact is
going to be less you know so again you
know all of us start you know disease
management starts with solve agronomy so
if you can remove that stress and manage
from an agronomic standpoint the disease
pressure is going to be less all rounds
and you know if you have power and you
know you have summer patch
your fun side is gonna work really well
this year because you're mowing at 150
not not 110 right so it's it's not that
so what we're saying the nuance of this
conversation for the people we're we're
not playing is is that there's other
things to factor even if you've always
done this because a significant part of
the puzzle has been taken out the the
traffic stress that you'd normally be
playing catch-up you're not having that
so that should be a bigger factor in
your decision now on the other side if
you're getting play like the guys
getting low n and minimal and raises the
risk for anthracnose so let's talk about
across the board if we're telling people
to slow growth that's it and you're
playing I don't think we're telling
people to slow growth if they're getting
300 rounds of golf right rich no hell no
man that man game on go go you know and
my friend in Long Island I've been
telling her you know you're coming out
of ant she's got anthracnose coming out
of the winter I mean you got you got
nitrogen you need to get down you need
the top dress she's fortunate because
she can mow at 156 right you know but
but it's game on for her you know so so
it's a if that's your situation this is
the normal year because does low n worry
you even when there's not play let's say
we're really working between regulations
and low end do we think we're going to
get more interact notes because we're
purposely not pushing growth or again
not pushing it with mowing and play is
gonna be the other factor yeah that's a
good question I don't know I guess that
remains to be seen you know if you're
slowing growth in your growth regulating
heavy to slow growth you know I remember
Dave Aude is saying Primo's of license
to fertilize right you got polling and
it's regulated and you know maybe you
want to jam a little bit more nitrogen
in there and these are the these are the
tricky things right so so this is what
everybody should be thinking about right
okay if I got a history of attract no
special
I'll pull an you and all negative words
we're talking about poet you don't see a
lot of anthracnose on bank rest do you
know we do but it's not it's not the
impact is nowhere near that's right
so we're talking about annual bluegrass
and we're basically saying once we get
going and this thing wants to take off
it's if it's if it's a significant part
of your standing you can't afford to
lose it there's this game you're going
to play but I guess what I you know
everybody knows me a long time the first
thing I'm thinking is why the hell are
we running to clear out the chemical
room to get out there and spray when
there's all these are the factors that
could mitigate whether we need to do it
or not rich and I brought you on to tell
me I'm either crazy and that these
people are gonna destroy their asset
they can't listen to me because I'm a
I'm a wild card and they're here in
major pathologies across the country I'm
not a pathologist telling them yeah you
better get it you better get it you
better get it down you better get down
and I'm just wondering have we just
gotten so used to this we can't stop
ourselves or is there other factors we
could be considering whoa again you have
a high-value asset and you want to sleep
at night you know you you you know and
it's and it's still what's it's a it's a
it's a Lomo you know it's not it's not
landscape turf if you guys are
landscapers I I tried to tell them that
we're talking the golf course
superintendent never spray a fungicide
at three inches of tall fescue happen
right but here maybe you do but I I
don't think you have to go into you know
I've seen advertisements from
manufacturers where you know you mixed
these three materials and you drench
them in for total season control and I
don't think you have to do that you know
I think moderation is good you know you
could probably get 21 to 28 days you
know pick pick a reasonable combination
of EMI and maybe a strobe II and you're
good and how much are we talking listen
again we're going through this with our
golf course superintendent at Cornell
I'm sure everybody's having this
conversation but you know the higher end
you get the more you can expand but
almost everything we're talking about is
for greens rich yes once we start
talking about fairways and tees what is
your how does that change your thinking
can you do you say
we need to be spraying these expansive
areas for the even the big what's risky
out there I gotta worry about yeah I'm
not worried about gray leaf spot right
now so what am I worried about okay Lee
spot and you know we're still off the
dollar spot for maybe five six weeks you
know in in New Jersey it's mid-may so
you're not to worry about dollar spot
you know a little bit of snow mold maybe
flaring up but it's gonna be shortly if
not you know it just gives you an
opportunity to see a little bit you know
right you get some more bentgrass or you
know if your ryegrass just you know see
ya same way right on your blue grass
weevils I don't you know let him eat the
eat the grass you don't want you know
and and and see and Katie's work just
showed that that's a viable strategy
yeah it and it is and I know guys with a
lot of bent grass and their fairways
that absolutely do it and it works all
right how are we doing on questions just
wondering I think Richie touched on it a
little bit
Brian was asked about you know nitrogen
leaching out over the winter and he sees
early season anthracnose would you
change any nitrogen recommendations
there based on that early season pattern
of anthracnose and potentially
potentially a nitrogen leach now well
you know night nitrogen rates
I guess play play a role and timing you
know but again just if you're spraying
it spraying it too you know what you
know in our research plots when at the
end of the season when they try to
recover the plots from the anthracnose
they just go out and spray like three
tanks every two weeks and grow the grass
out of him right so maybe that's what
you need to do now there's a little bit
more grow the grass out of it
you're regulating it so you you know I
get the top growth so much yeah and
that's all you need to do and and and
before we go I just want to let me let
me do this one more time Carl I just
want to make sure we have some sense of
this I mean I you know and again there's
lots of ways to look at growth but
fundamentally we're not growing a lot
now right the only way you're going to
get some increased growth
is is to get that soil warmer and and
and really drive more nitrogen that's
gonna get into that plant but if we stay
wet and cool which is expected I don't
really see ways that we're going to be
able to push a lot of growth even with
tons of end that's one of the problems
we have with spring sports when we talk
to our sports guys on on you know
tomorrow that's a big issue they're not
getting any play right now but again
everything gets modified if you have
traffic there's only so much you can
push things in fact you're better off
warming it with pigments right now
drawing heat to it to sort of get it
going get that soil temperature
ultimately soil temperatures going to
terminate of ability when they spray
those plots with three tenths of n I'm
sure to soil seventy five degrees at
that time rich those plants are ready to
grow grow yeah yeah they grow right out
of it Queen Queen looks like there was
no problems and if you don't spray for a
dollar spa how much am i I saw Paul Koch
sting at the University of Wisconsin
website they got a really nice covered
website Carl we should direct people to
it's got bugs excel sheet on and Paul
Koch said don't worry about the house
pot when you get back you can fertilize
it'll grow yeah but but but rich it's
you know it want to sleep at night you
got to protect the acid I'm not
promoting this as old Rossy says you
just let the place go know when you've
got to balance the safety and welfare of
a population especially in New York City
in a metropolitan area I'm gonna go to
what the USGA said these are
unprecedented times you've got to do
things differently then you've done them
and what we're trying to do in our
little half an hour with you is get
somebody smart with me so that I don't
say crazy things that people don't and
then hopefully process what's that rich
optimistic comment
so anyway Carl we got other questions
that were good to go half hours perfect
timing the quickest in turf no no other
questions so I think we'll wrap it at
that rich thanks again for hopping on
and having a good chat I know we do this
a lot you know a phone call itself
obviously Frank that's right thanks I
finally
get to see all the memorabilia from the
Dead concerts how cool is that we got to
do a little room tour we're rich Buckley
reminiscing how many shows total with
Garcia over 200 oh how many sins
aa bunch of much I haven't counted but I
have I had tickets to Six coming up so
alright thanks very much rich talk to
you tomorrow everybody great meeting
Carl thanks a lot thanks everybody guys
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu